[Music]
in starving artists news oh not me
me I got all kinds of food likes it
right here keeping me fat oh my god hey
baby
two locations submitted by the end is
near oh no it's the end of the world as
we know it
no I feel fine so research suggests that
artists are often poor because of their
brain chemistry
I believe it they just suck with money
and they don't have discipline so
they're gonna stick to something they
want to do things by feel a long time
what does that mean about me
you're not a true artist bro hmm oh
you're just a business man hmm playin
artists that's not offensive yeah so
there was this study the sample size was
really small there's 24 people okay so
it's so this [ __ ] is a [ __ ] it's an
introductory test it's a [ __ ] college
test that they do for their midterms and
[ __ ] for statistic success statistic or
maybe all the other artists is dropped
out they're so [ __ ] late
all of my [ __ ] truest artist friends
can I hold down jack [ __ ] these people
twelve of these people were artists like
either actors painters sculptors
musicians or photographers and the other
12 were like an insurance salesmen
dentists business administrator and
engineer just so people would like
quote-unquote stable jobs or whatever
yeah who do I self-identify none of who
self-identify
it's creative gotcha yeah so what they
did is the researcher the research team
they were watching for activity in the
parts of the brain that produced
dopamine which is that chemical that
delivers the rush of excitement I love
it because that's what drugs gave me
mm-hmm all right so each participant
wore a set of goggles and in these
goggles ahead a series of squares with
different colors and so they were
instructed that whenever the green
square appeared that they could select
it with the button and receive money
that was up to 30 euros and then they
were also select they were also asked to
select other target colors with those
did not result in monetary reward and so
what they found is that the artists show
significantly reduced activation of
dopamine when they selected the
money-making green squares compared to
non-parties I know so much so the
insurance tile is like green green green
and it's like when the artist was like
green that's like you win a hundred
bucks a thirty-year-old
that's so [ __ ] true though because we
know a lot of people that can get [ __ ]
done immediately if they [ __ ] love
the project yet no matter how much you
pay him like they won't they just don't
they won't do [ __ ] that's so true yep
yeah we know one guy that was offered
like five hundred bucks to drop off
something and he didn't want to do it it
wasn't even illegal if you're thinking
no no no it was literally like camera
equipment and it was already in the same
office all he had to do was he was
already going to somewhere all you had
to do was pick up the stuff and he's
already going to this [ __ ] convention
to this booth and he had to walk three
booths over to drop off the camera
equipment but he didn't want to do it
too much responsibility too much
pressure that's some irresponsible ass
[ __ ] no stupidity yeah I do but he don't
care he don't give a [ __ ] about money
and then I heard that like if you want
things done you have to really play like
on the on what he values
he cares about this project so he's
gonna [ __ ] kill it he's gonna do a
great job but if you if you give him
more money he's like so I don't care to
know you could buy me for pretty much
anything
yeah me too yeah the prostitute yeah so
the researchers also found that during
the second test that whenever the
artists were told to reject the green
squares meaning that they weren't gonna
get the money they had a greater
response and the dopamine related parts
of the brain so so artists are like
[ __ ] it in a burn isn't it and you
get more activity so it means like they
have a blast burning money so they get
less worked up about receiving money but
more worked up when they know that they
can't have it that just doesn't make any
sense
they can't work cool to struggle yeah I
bet you all these subjects are not even
professional artists and they just
[ __ ] like kids
wait what like college students oh
[ __ ] like kids yeah
they're like [ __ ] they are like
children kids no okay cuz professional
artists are technically a little bit on
the business side see I did have a
working job design that works like at a
firm 9:00 to 5:00 or they're so [ __ ]
talented like Michael Jackson he was
bankrupt and blowing so much [ __ ]
money but it doesn't even matter because
they keep making more money as long as
going bankrupt well Jackson you got into
trouble really
now we know why you're buying Jurassic
yes so we should all we saw this clip of
Michael Jackson visiting Mandalay Bay
going into this really posh but like
super gaudy store and then just going
I'll take that I'll take that and it was
the gaudiest [ __ ] paintings basis
gargoyle statues yeah there was like
this one statue that was like half a
million dollars and he was like I'll
take that and that and then someone's
riding
so nobody makes it sure we're now
fighting it down are you am I gonna
remember all this you're like sure I'd
have it okay and the person was like oh
yeah it's about like a million dollar so
far he goes oh don't worry he's gonna
give me a good deal within seconds Yuri
racked up millions of dollars I'm
getting doubt right okay yeah you see
look how beautiful that is
he's just going around picking all these
things I get it now she looks ugly as
[ __ ] to a [ __ ] all these artists that
are like super centric and pro like
they're making mad money but then
they're spending my money yeah cuz they
don't care about it yeah love blowing it
they love it maybe they feel a sense of
stress like knowing that this thing is
like controlling them if they're just
like I'm not working for this I'm
working for my own happiness and this is
just the result of what I get but then
when they're like you got to work for
this or like [ __ ] I don't want it that's
like that's like I want to be a
billionaire so I could live in a hut
that's literally what you want the
opposite yeah I mean it's the opposite
of why people want money you know like
people want money so they can [ __ ]
have a big house and you don't have to
live in it your house and in the
backyard
I'm gonna have a heart okay okay told
you she'll be caught it yeah I said no
that it's not gonna happen and then once
he said that he's gonna have it in the
back I said it would have to be way in
the back cuz she's not gonna approve it
if it's in her site so she can see it
she's gonna be like no I don't want that
[ __ ] cuz I think she wants it ugly she
probably wants it far enough where when
Joe walks out of his house the mud on
his on his feet the footprints made by
could fade off ladies I could this is
where my house starts and this is what
your house done and I'm gonna install a
foot wash right before I get in right
there yeah
but yeah in a foot wash
it's gonna be slightly if he's paying
for it all you can he can put his little
footprints all over it and it will have
robots that clean it all robots yeah
it'll be wait for this to probably do it
now you know you know robots as a
billionaire oh my gosh the little mop
bot yeah what are they you know buzz
rumors but remember it's just a vacuum
know that mom
there's mop BOTS oh [ __ ] where in the
future I'd rather just have an actual
maid but yeah either way me to provide a
salary for someone yeah yeah create jobs
yeah
yes but they have to be a really
handsome man okay has to be a handsome
[ __ ] with a six-pack to be
shirtless so he's not stealing [ __ ] with
the [ __ ] bowtie cuz I want him to
still be classy and I'm gonna have a
bunch of those dudes in the house by
yourself yeah while I stay in the hunt
and he has lotion all over his body so I
can see him in the dark
yup so he's glistening I don't even
trust him with pants because he might
steal [ __ ] so he can only in their other
wear and make sure that there's nothing
in there
damn Jess you have it wrong now chicks
cuz that makes that makes me feel like a
man that I own all these other men you
know what I mean like like I don't want
I don't wanna I don't want all these
women I want to be
there's no owning there's employing yeah
and no no no I'm owning like this this
is this is like okay now I feel weird
and it's multicultural laning the appeal
of slavery man they felt like men yeah
it made them feel like men no now we
know I think yeah see it did they had a
they had to prove to the world that
their big men just like me but I don't
want no girls no girls [ __ ] that no no I
try to do I try to do the guy thing
because I don't want to be misogynistic
I was thinking about the women and I was
thinking about the old ladies that are
that are tired and then whatever right
but you can't win dude dude slavery
right I wasn't thinking about black guys
[Music]
to Steve green is prime example yes I've
seen I see no like didn't say he told us
and then Bart wanted a touches yeah a
hard day I saw being asked why I got at
the big old dick tumor so we can employ
him in the contact with them anymore you
can't win dude I was trying to be like I
don't want any girls dicks I feel bad
but you start to go into the slavery
round though you said Oh
employees if you w to remember though
we're not gonna be in America anymore by
that time so it's okay what you're
saying everyone is my children how about
that
[Music]
[Music]